Last spring, a couple friends of mine,
Jack and Hans, were having a disagreement,
and that disagreement was about buff spells. Jack
was insisting that they’re largely pretty bad and
a waste of deck space in just about all formats,
whereas Hans was passionately defending them as
an underrated type of card. After the conversation
was over, Hans, looking intensely off into space,
simply said “I need to make a buff spells
deck now.” And in the following weeks,
he did just that—he went for Temur colors, and
built it dirt cheap—as it turns out, buff spells
are quite inexpensive, even the good ones. He
started with Pako and Haldan as the commanders,
which performed roughly as you’d expect for a $20
buff spells deck—it was a mediocre midrange deck
with some funky combat tricks, and Pako ate
his fair share of removal spells. But then,
Hans switched out the commander
for a much spicier choice—Xyris,
the Writhing Storm. Suddenly, the deck
started performing very differently.
Games with this version of Xyris start off pretty
unassumingly—the deck typically plays a ramp spell
and some sort of value creature turns 2 and 3, and
then plays its commander turn 4 or 5. From there,
it typically ramps a bit more, plays another
creature or two, and hits the person at the
table who is doing the worst. Combat step with
the Xyris deck generally sees Hans saying “who
wants to draw some cards?” and then, as promised,
letting a person he’s okay with drawing cards,
along with himself, draw cards. If a player kept
a risky hand and is getting flooded or screwed,
Xyris is here to save them, to bestow upon them
the gift of three, or six, or even nine cards.
And this is the trap the deck lays—seeming like a
friend. I have seen a manascrewed player counter
an opposing removal spell that targets Xyris
simply because they were desperate to keep drawing
those cards. The deck is friendly and unassuming
right up until the point where it decides to stop
being those things and start murdering players.
Because fun fact—letting you and an opponent each
draw 15 cards is great when that opponent
simultaneously dies to commander damage.
Relevant to the way this deck operates in practice
is the Smol Bean Syndrome video I made awhile
back. Hans plays the deck totally straight—he
doesn’t emphasize the deck’s power, nor its lack
of power—but the deck nonetheless heavily plays
on the perceptions of its opponents. The deck is
pretty predictable if you stop and take a moment
to think about it—it’s about 20% buff spells,
10% protection spells, 10% removal spells, and an
assortment of lands, ramp, and utility creatures
from there. When you know how many cards the
deck has drawn, you can guess the approximate
composition of its current hand—very little in
the deck is fully unique. And if you were to think
about this constantly, to realize that the deck
is probably currently holding multiple protection
spells, fight spells, and/or buff spells at a
given moment, and is going to get escalating
numbers of these things on the coming turns, you
might get worried about what the deck is doing,
and correctly so. But nobody seems to do this
sort of analysis—this deck gets underestimated
game after game, and by people who have lost to it
half a dozen or more times. Even I frequently find
myself underestimating the deck, specifically
because individual cards in the deck aren’t
very memorable. The deck’s lack of spicy plays and
absolute transparency in what it’s trying to do in
a given game play to its strengths—it effortlessly
slides to the back of its opponents’ minds as
that pile of bulk commons that will draw them some
cards, and it stays there until it’s far too late.
I say far too late, because this deck more or
less operates on the snowball principle—early
in the game it doesn’t have many buff spells,
protection spells, or removal spells. However,
as it accumulates cards from Xyris hits it has
more and more resources to protect its gameplan
and stop other people, and by the time it has
killed a player, it has access to basically
whatever resources from its deck that it wants. In
addition, the threat profile of the deck typically
lags behind its actual power—at any given moment,
people are usually concerned about the deck in the
amount they should have been concerned about it
a turn or two previously. However, despite not
presenting as a deck the table should be worried
about winning, the deck does cultivate a specific,
more mundane type of fear in its opponents, a fear
created directly from the act of running a lot of
buff spells. The combination of the deck being 20%
buff spells and it drawing a lot of cards gives an
impression of an endless stream of buff spells.
When it comes down to it, the deck’s supply of
buff spells is finite, it is spending resources to
use them, and it does run out of them sometimes.
But the deck’s opponents nonetheless learn to
exist in a constant state of fear during the
combat step—can I attack the Xyris player with my
5/5 trampler? No, they have a 1/1 Snake they can
block with, I don’t wanna lose my creature. Should
I block that Catgeist? Well no, of course not, do
I look like somebody who throws my threats in the
garbage? This might seem like a minor factor, but
like many other aspects of the deck it’s a dynamic
that hinders its opponents’ abilities to work
together to slow it down. In theory if a player
is far ahead, you can make use of the multiplayer
nature of the format—two or more opponents trading
cards one for one as blockers or through removal
spells will wear down a deck overtime. And if
anything this is more true in the case of opposing
decks forcing Xyris to use buff spells outside of
dealing combat damage to a player—the deck’s happy
place is when it pours three to four buff spells
into killing a player with Xyris and restocking
its hand, and every buff spell it uses on damage
not being dealt to an opponent sets it back from
getting to that place. But the impression
of a neverending tide of buff spells, paired
with the deck’s delayed threat profile, keeps
opponents from playing this way in most games.
The snakes Xyris creates bolster these
characteristics—both the way the deck
discourages its opponents from trying to engage
with it during the combat step and the snowball
factor. Xyris generates a lot of snakes—even if
its opponents aren’t running draw of any kind,
it’s still generating as many snakes as the
commander deals damage. That means three per
turn at minimum, and a dozen or more per turn
once the deck hits its stride. The result of this
compounds with the nature of being a buff spells
deck—the deck gains piles and piles of potential
attackers and blockers that could get larger
and gain all manner of potentially problematic
keywords at any moment. This also plays into the
snowball factor—once opponents catch onto how
concerning the deck is, even if they manage to
dump enough removal into the commander to break
through the deck’s protection spells, they’re
still going to have a lot of snakes to deal with.
If there are enough of these snakes, they alone
could be adequate to push through for the win,
as the benefit of having a wide board of
attackers means that the deck can pile buff
spells onto the unblocked snakes, effectively
creating a sort of evasion where the deck can
decide to have a specific snake be its scary
attacker after blockers are already declared.
The snake problem isn’t impossible to overcome,
though, and one good way to shut it down is to
play a board wipe. And actually, this can even
be a good way to deal with the deck’s commander
as well, since of its 11 cards that could be
considered protective, 5 of them are entirely
useless against board wipes and the other 6 are
only situationally useful. So are board wipes this
deck’s achilles heel? Kind of but not exactly, and
to explain why I need to talk about the ways decks
store accumulated resources. Most commander decks
tend to have some focus on building up resources,
and a key question is what the deck does with
those resources to push its advantage but also
avoid losing them all. That key question’s
answer is the Ezuri-Kyler Scale of Accumulated
Resource Permanency, trademark pending. Basically,
planeswalker emblems and experience counters are
the most permanent type of resource as something
that opponents literally can’t interact with,
generally followed by lands, cards in hand,
a variety of different nonland permanents,
and a single type of nonland permanent, with
creatures whose presence on the board holds up
a deck’s entire gameplan such as Kyler or Chainer
being the most vulnerable way to store resources.
The Xyris buff spells deck is among
the decks that treat cards in hand as
their primary place to store resources, but
these decks differ widely, with one axis of
difference being especially key—velocity.
Control decks, combo decks, and a decent
portion of high-curved midrange decks will place
high value on the stuff they have in their hand,
but they generally play that stuff slowly—their
turnover of the stuff in their hand is pretty low,
an attribute we could call being low velocity.
By contrast, Xyris buff spells is a very high
velocity deck—buff spells can essentially
be thought of as creatures that cost only a
fraction as much but stick around for a single
turn, and in later turns the deck will often
churn through 5 or more of these per turn. The
result of this is that Xyris buff spells will be
somewhat resilient to board wipes, since most
of Xyris’s power is stored in the deck’s hand
and it can rapidly play them out the next turn
it has a creature to swing with. However, its
high velocity also means that if the deck’s draw
is cut off multiple turns in a row, or if it loses
Xyris at a moment where it’s already low on buff
spells, it will struggle to get back on its feet.
With this weakness in mind, I feel
I should clarify what I mean when I
call this my playgroup’s best deck. This
isn’t a deck that generally dukes it out
with high powered combo decks—it would
have a hard time in those games. No,
this is a deck that gets pulled out in
low-medium power games—on paper it’s Hans’
least powerful deck. And I think it shouldn’t go
understated just how unassuming this deck seems,
even having seen it in action—it’s mostly bulk
commons, it’s pretty dependent on the commander,
it’s not very fast, the manabase is almost
entirely basics and taplands, and its core
category of card is usually relegated to being
played in limited and maybe the fastest of
aggro decks. This deck doesn’t seem very good, and
that perception is exactly what makes it so good,
what causes it to win the vast majority of games
it’s featured in. The deck could absolutely be
improved in terms of raw power level, especially
with another $20-30 in budget—it could run
a couple more counterspells, it could run some
protective equipments, it could run better ramp,
and most importantly, it could pop in 2-3 cards
that give unlimited hand size, which would on
paper eliminate one of its key weaknesses.
But here’s the thing—doing those things would
turn this deck into a more generic Voltron deck,
one that is obviously threatening and is a very
visible ticking time bomb for everybody at the
table as long as Xyris is in play. I’ve argued in
the past that Reliquary Tower is overrated, and
this is a strange case where it actually would
be quite good from a power level standpoint,
and yet it’s still correct not to include it.
Discarding to hand size is the final dynamic
that causes people to underestimate the deck—if
the deck has a fistful of ten or fifteen or even
twenty cards, it’s obviously a threat. But when
you watch the deck discard back down to seven, you
have to ask yourself “come on, how good could that
hand possibly be?” And in this case, you wouldn’t
even be wrong to ask that. There are only so many
protection spells and buff spells and other types
of spells that a seven card hand can contain,
and the deck does need to balance inflicting
lethal combat damage with protecting the commander
and retaining the ability to deal with opposing
threats. In this way, not running unlimited hand
size cards makes the deck more interesting
to play against, and also more interesting
to play. In later turns the discard phase becomes
a critical decision-point, where the Xyris player
must carefully plan out their resources and try
to navigate around what their opponents are going
to do. It’s like a turn-based boss fight where
the boss needs to carefully allot resources in
order to best ward off the encroachments of the
other players—it’s honestly really cool, and it’s
kinda hard to ever be mad at the Xyris deck for
this reason even as it tends to pull off wins in
the end regardless. Paradoxically, the Xyris buff
spells deck has the highest winrate of any deck
in my playgroup because of how dynamic and how
fair it is. The deck is a masterclass in playing
commander in the purest sense—it does a good job
of creating interesting gameplay for everybody at
the table, and that interesting gameplay itself
greatly contributes to its ability to win games.
Thanks for watching! I had planned to release a
video about navigating power levels this week, but
I couldn’t quite get the script where I wanted it
in time, so I decided to make this video instead.
You can expect that power level video next week,
though. I will also be posting an endnote to this
video tomorrow over on my Patreon that addresses
a particular deckbuilding style that was utilized
in making this deck, so if you aren’t giving me
money yet, now is a pretty cool time to start!